last time we were playing um a game on a
terminal
and uh you sort of teased a little bit
about what was to come next so where did
we go with this
yeah we're playing the game of rogue
which was one of these early
terminal based games but had this
terminal addressing so it could jump
around the screen and draw
you know a nice map and so on but i'd
sometimes thought perhaps we could uh
i don't know code up something to play
it myself but no it looks
really really complicated
firstly you've got to interpret all this
screen stuff and make your own map and
then it's a fairly random game so you've
got to take decisions at every point and
thought
yeah well anyway i've got some other
work i should be doing anyway
but then across the internet as it was
some people at carnegie mellon
university had taken on the challenge
uh in fact four of them michael mauldin
dwight jacobson
andrew apple and leonard hammy they'd
actually uh
investigated this they got a system that
could interpret
all these codes coming to you instead of
going to the screen they sort of
intercepted them
and understood them and made their own
map of the dungeon
and then they had a quite sophisticated
exploration program
so there's a lot of path finding to work
out how to get from
a to b and uh what to do when you met a
monster
and it got more more sophisticated and
the version i
eventually got hold of at a genetic
learning component which i think you've
done a video on it so
this is quite a reasonable thing to do
because nobody actually knew how to play
the game
perfectly there are so many decisions
and things
you know do you do you keep running away
from the monster and hope that uh you'll
recover and fight another day or just
just go in there and hack them to bits
and
uh hope that you survive and so they had
genes for each of these things you know
how how aggressive should i be towards a
monster
how much time should i spend exploring
this level and
uh when should i stop and just go down
to the next level because the rewards
are better down there but the monsters
are bigger so if you played it enough
times
it would decide which of these were the
best opportunities and they started off
i think
with about eight or nine of these genes
that
looked at different things i expanded it
considerably i think i had 250
in the version i've got some of them
don't do anything
but uh it's always good to have some
spare ones around
so uh that that was quite uh an
impressive game and it
it did actually do very well they did
actually win the game
uh at least once there was a bit of a
uh war between the implementers of that
and the game rogue itself so as new
versions of rogue came out they would
subtly tweak things so that this program
would no longer work
the text that came you know you hit that
monster really well or something they
changed that to you scored a great hit
and then the program was hard-coded to
do certain things when it got a certain
message and then if you tweet the
message
the program stops working yes exactly
that yeah in one case they went for
capitalization so you had capitalization
the beginning of the phrase and
they changed the words they changed the
monsters so it got more and more
sophisticated so that it could actually
um
play against several versions of this
that was in sort of the
late 80s i think i got hold of the first
version i just kept tinkering with it
it was sort of my go-to project when i
was born without anywhere else i was
doing like a
tinker with that as systems evolved it
stopped working
computer operating systems had changed i
had to port it to the new versions
and uh the way it interacted with game
change somewhat
so i had to do that and then i went on
to this genetic learning
my latest version which i started uh i
guess
the beginning of this year somewhere in
the middle of lockdown anyway
uh was to rewrite it all in c plus plus
the original was written in c
so i thought that there's a new c plus
version come out c plus plus 17 has a
few
new features so i thought it'd be nice
to try exploring that with um
a proper project i also embedded another
language called lua i don't know if
you've done
anything on lua no no it's a kind of
language that's supposed to be embedded
in other
programs so if you want to
tweak how your program runs lure is very
easy to embed in another language
another program and it allows you to
sort of configure it
and it has arithmetic and string
matching and
all that sort of stuff so you just make
calls into your program
and call out to this program and then
you can have a whole script that does
things it's very popular in games
so you could sort of uh have the
the heavy lifting of the game done in c
plus plus and then you can have these
scripts that
control how things move spaceships move
or
monsters move or whatever you can just
uh it's
of course it's very quick to then code
it up because it's all interpreted
so i put that in so that uh i could
adapt to new versions
because there's uh there's really only
about three or four versions but since
that time
newer systems have ported it people have
reinvented it
uh there was rogue there was super rogue
there was ultra rogue
there was net hack and net hack was
beyond a
rogumatic system which is what this
system was called that was far too
uh complicated did quite a lot of work
on this i've still never won the game
even with the help of uh rogomatic
uh it's got further than i ever did but
uh it has a recording system built into
it where
you can either start recording at the
beginning or you can record it in a time
or it automatically starts recording if
you go below
level 18 it says all right this this is
a good game i better save this
is it a bit like watching something on
fast forward if you run it at full speed
and um
you can actually hardly see it get a
longer game
another way you can run it is terse mode
in which case it just
prints out what it's doing each time
that's that's what i used to run it in
because it was a
a bit of a cpu hog it doesn't these days
we've got
much bigger programs these days but when
when you were time sharing with lots of
other people then
you had to keep it running slowly
there any stupid mistakes it makes or
what we would call ridiculous mistakes
there are some mistakes it certainly
makes uh
so and particularly of the newer
versions where i haven't
quite got all the subtleties coded up
so that there's one case where it goes
into a room sees a monster
and says all right okay i better get
into the monster fight or flight mode
you know do i go and attack it or not
decides to uh not attack it because it's
look to the statistics and decide it's
perhaps not a good idea
so it backs out of the room but in this
version once you back out of the room
the room goes dark
and everything is hidden and it then
re-evaluates and says oh
i was going into a room there and
there's no reason i shouldn't go into it
so it goes back into it the monster
reappears
oh no backs out again so it just
shuffles backwards and forwards there's
several cases where it gets stuck into
those sorts of loops
and they're usually cured by another
monster wandering up
and making you reevaluate your decision
so suddenly you've got to take an action
and that's what
pushes you into uh things there is a
bug in the curses version that the very
early one uses that draws walls wrong
occasionally and that that really
confuses it
and roger matic settles on a set of
genes eventually but it takes
a few thousand runs to actually really
refine it down
to something and then as you add more
genes it's it's more complexity so it
takes
takes even longer to settle down then
how long does a few thousand
runs take now probably a few hours i
guess to to get through that sort of
thing it's the sort of thing
as long as i i work really hard to try
and
make sure it never froze so that it
either
completed the game or just quit or or
just gave up
so that you could have a script that
would continue to run it so you could
leave it running go to bed and wake up
in the morning and there'll be a few
thousand
runs done by that time what used to
happen is you'd leave it going and the
second one it would get hung up
somewhere and just
sort of lock lock up into the system and
not give you any useful data
the guys who wrote the rogomatic the
these people at cnu
they actually got sponsored or got
sponsored partly by the dod
under the arpa project so they got some
i don't know
quite uh how they managed to wrangle
that
we want to write a program to play a
game and that's just the sort of things
the defense
systems would like is it well we've all
watched war games so who knows
yes yes yes do you want to play a game
yes it's probably better than global
third
nuclear war certainly i don't profess to
be an expert in game theory at all but
obviously the the ideas behind
coming up with challenges and solving
those challenges has got to be
interesting to anyone who's in kind of
war games i suppose
yeah especially i guess this one because
the logic is not
fixed you have to adapt to it and be a
learning learning uh idea with
the genetic stuff that's always
it was very early days it was the first
time i'd ever heard of genetic
algorithms
wow what are these and so i spent a
while playing with them
but i've never used them seriously apart
from enrogamatic
which you can go back to your computer
and now you've got a message from this
first hop go again set the time to lift
to two
it decrements to one decrements again
and now
it's a little bit longer then we've got
sixty possible positions
one we've got a two three out of five
and then